this episode is made possible by
dashlane secure your data from prying
eyes by signing up for a free account
today for almost the entirety of human
history we've always had a bit of a
thing for predicting the future
sometimes we get pretty close and
sometimes we're way off in this episode
we're going to look at a few of the
notable examples since the early 20th
century when we really began to wonder
how modern and future technology would
change our lives and the world we'll
start with one topic that people still
love to theorize about today the future
of cars back in the late 30s and 40s
cars had officially become a staple of
modern society and as a relatively new
technology people were always thinking
up new ways to make them even better in
the 1930s the predictions for the future
of cars were pretty tame not many dreams
of flying cars yet the development of
more complete streamlining for motor
cars will be the problem of Engineers of
tomorrow
someday this problem will finally be
solved sometime in the future the
completely streamlined torpedo car may
come into use elevated highways wide and
level may let us go 120 miles an hour
but such a torpedo car on our streets
today would be entirely impractical
people simply expected the engineers of
the future to design faster safer and
more aerodynamic vehicles in that regard
they were absolutely right after the war
we saw films like this one from 1948
people were beginning to experiment more
and we got to see some unusual
contraptions
chariot can really run you around in
circles what's the trouble Gary
Oh modern Frankenstein and here's
another streamlined marvel on wheels it
only needs a pair of wings to be at home
in the sky formidable indeed is its nose
with riveted aluminum fuselage entry
hatch and rugged and panache it's
wasting time on the ground but being
earthbound the monster is traveled out
out of the highway to frighten other
motivations if you're looking for a 1960
model this may well be it a lot of these
design elements seem kind of ridiculous
to us now incorporating airplane
features and controls didn't really
catch on mostly because it was
unnecessary and complicated that being
said we have seen a few three-wheeled
cars and reversed three-wheeled car
things and some of the aesthetic
elements of late 40s concept cars have
snuck into modern styling for example
this one looks a lot like a current
Rolls Royce concept in the mid 1950s we
really began to see some sci-fi ideas
take shape flying cars hover cars and of
course self-driving cars the idea of
self-driving cars isn't new but the
implementation is very different instead
of computers Manning the controls in
this film the cars of the future were
imagined to be guided by magnetic strips
in the road with a bit of information
from control towers and the driver power
to Firebird to tower to Firebird to all
traffic moving in normal pattern fb-22
tower we're heading for Chicago
please route us through over
well done Firebird - you're now under
automatic control hands off steering
[Music]
here we go on the high speed safety lane
[Music]
ah they comfortable my probes are as
different as self-driving cars look
today they are catching on and it looks
like these predictions while several
decades off are actually pretty accurate
at least at surface level besides cars
we've always been fascinated with how
the people of the future might live what
will their homes look like what amazing
new technologies will they have at their
disposal
what will the fashion look like the
people of the 1920s had some interesting
ideas when it came to clothing most
famous fashion designers in the u.s.
today have been asked to forecast what
Eve will look like in AD 2000 one idea
is a dress that can be adapted for
morning afternoon or evening
it's the sleeves what does it apparently
in AD 2000 we shall be having a
hair-raising time yet another designer
goes so far as to believe that skirts
will disappear entirely shoes will have
cantilever heels and an electric belt
will adapt the body to climatic changes
the likely clared woman of tomorrow ooh
swish will move in an atmosphere that
scientifically kept at the right
temperature the future bride in a
wedding dress of glass what the grumble
we're apart from a worid look isn't
mentioned a dress of aluminium with a
sash to change it for afternoon or
evening an electric headlight to help
her to find an honest man as for him if
he matters at all he'll be fitted with a
telephone a radio and containers for
coins keys and candy for cutie in some
ways they were right dresses have lost
some ground to pants shorts and skirts
but they're still very much a part of
modern clothing and in some ways they
were hilariously wrong light bulb head
where a chest-mounted phone they were at
least correct in assuming we'd have
phones with us pretty much all the time
kitchens maybe the thing that's changed
the least since these predictions from
the 50s but it's interesting to see what
people expected and how societal norms
have changed
press button dream coming true for mrs.
housewife all sorts of wonders are hers
at the push of a button from
refrigerator doors to countertops built
for big gals or little gals don't have
to lean over here you see what's for
dinner consult the menus on pictures and
dish up something new for a change
hummingbird wings on toast maybe and
look where the toaster is a wave of the
hand and presto down comes a hidden
cabinet with the dishes
mama will feel like a fairy princess
with a magic wand in a place like this
we won't be able to get her out of the
kitchen but we'll cross that bridge when
we get to it right now the question
before the house is what's cooking and
when you eat the interesting thing about
this particular film is that all of
these changes are completely unnecessary
and would definitely slow you down in
the kitchen the closest thing to being
accurate from this film is probably the
video screen recipes it's not something
that's built into modern kitchens but we
do often use phones or tablets instead
of cookbooks to find recipes as we
entered the 60s and saw the advent of
computer technology people began to
really consider what these new machines
could do in the future this is the point
in history where our prediction started
to align more with reality except for
our weird fascination with truly useless
robots here we see a woman ordering a
giant slow lumbering robot to do menial
tasks such as open the door or light a
candle all of these things could have
been accomplished much more quickly
without the Robo Butler but when you
think about it we actually do have some
machines that do our bidding they may
not be seven-foot-tall abominations but
we can order them to play music
give us the weather or change the
lighting and of course the fascination
with humanoid robots never really went
away we're still working on creating
them but we're more interested in the
artificial intelligence aspect than
having a mechanical servant to do our
chores
besides the nightmarish slave robots
that thankfully never came to be some
predictions from the 60s ended up very
close to reality for example this film
from the early 60s explains how children
will do the majority of their learning
through computers
Master James sure eight years old
student attends formal school two
morning's a week much of his education
however is carried on in a kind of
education center within the home and fed
into teaching machines which allow him
to progress as rapidly as his Awakening
mind can absorb the audiovisual lessons
they did guess that this would be the
norm by the year 1999 so they weren't
exactly right in that regard but they
were pretty close we did have
educational games and programs by then
but we didn't really start to see proper
web-based online classes for another
several years this clip from 1961 shows
a woman buying clothes from the comfort
of her own home while looking at
pictures of it on a digital screen
sounds pretty familiar yellow I don't
know do you have it in green certainly
here it is
yes fine that's it I'll take it please
send it out to me here's my credit card
oh and don't forget the stripe
pillowcases no we won't this prediction
wasn't completely accurate as the woman
is still interacting with another human
on the phone but ordering things from
your own home device has become the
backbone of 21st century shopping just
six years after that prediction from
1961 we get this a much more accurate
batch of predictions centered around the
importance of so-called home video
screens which clearly became modern
desktop computers in this film we see a
woman buying clothes again but this time
there's no human interaction required
later we see the husband paying for the
clothes accessing his bank account and
sending electronic letters all from the
home video screen system paid for by the
husband at his counterpart console all
bills and transactions will be carried
out electronically a central bank
computer will debit the family's account
the amount of purchases and credit the
department store for example informing
the family's home computer at the same
time
father at the touch of a button receives
an instantaneous printed copy of his
budget the amount of taxes he owes the
payments left on the car and so forth
all documents and household records are
available on the video screen for
immediate reference also at his disposal
is an electronic correspondence machine
or home post office which allows for
instant written communication between
individuals anywhere in the world while
it may not be super refined this whole
system is a very accurate representation
of how we use modern computers we shop
online pay bills and view bank
statements and send emails as the 60s
drew to a close we started seeing more
reasonable predictions mostly because
our understanding of computer technology
allowed us to make more educated guesses
in regards to further development of
course we never stopped making guesses
about the future and even today we see
some truly sci-fi predictions but that's
a topic for a future video now with all
these advancements in computing
technology it stands to reason that the
good people of the future will need a
way to protect their valuable
information from digital criminals
consider for a moment the service that
secures your personal information by way
of automatically generated strings of
letters numbers and symbols which the
computer savvy call passwords this is a
scale model of the home computer of the
future with the magic of modern film we
can demonstrate how this futuristic
information security service will
operate the average Joe of the future
has a lot on his plate and doesn't want
to remember all these different
passwords and everyone knows one mustn't
use the same password for everything
with this new service let's call it -
Lane he doesn't have to the application
a word used to describe future computer
programs can be accessed on his home
computer or handheld computing device
which will be commonplace in the year
2018 he can rest easy knowing that even
the most sophisticated computer criminal
can't steal his information because -
Lane is locally secured which means the
passwords are only stored on his
machines if Joe everyman is
inexperienced with home computers - Lane
takes care of his security for him
allowing even a simpleton to
automatically change unsafe passwords
the program also allows users to store
often used information like credit card
numbers for digital shopping the
electronic mail addresses and telephone
numbers which can be used to
automatically fill-in digital forms
greatest minds predicted television
programs and films will be widely
available through entertainment services
on the computers of the future knowing
this the secure sharing of passwords
between friends and family who don't use
these services will be a popular feature
allowing loved ones to catch up on
season 100 of The Andy Griffith Show
security peace of mind and convenience
all of these features and more will be
included in the best computer programs
of the future now that prediction was
accurate protect your passwords for free
by downloading dashlane today as a
special thanks for fans of second
thought you can get a 30-day free trial
of dashlane premium plus 10% off your
premium subscription by following the
link below and using the code second
thought it's available for Mac PC iOS
and Android so whether you up for the
free or premium account I can't
recommend Ashley and highly enough so to
support the channel and secure your
valuable data check out - Lane at the
link below
[Music]